So thank you very much for watching this video today on the foliage settings, the advanced
foliage and grass placement settings.
We've talked about the tools, the types, foliage, LOD, a few tips and tricks.
Hopefully it just gave you a good kind of onboarding onto your journey using foliage,
what all the different buttons are doing.
And a lot of it is just playing around with the different brush sizes and densities and
ticking tick boxes and unticking them and just seeing what results you can get.
Again, hopefully we pointed you in the right direction of some tools that can help automate
your life a little bit, you know, rather than having to go through and place individual
bushes and rocks.
Hopefully it gave you some good indication about what you might be able to apply to your
projects.
So thank you again for watching and we'll see you in the next video.